いやぁ...もう3年前か...
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
この季節はですね、結構いろんな地域で成人式が行われていると思います。
僕の弟もですね、今年で成人なので今たぶん成人式に行っている頃でしょう。
おめでとう！
いや、もう、あー！！
もう懐かしいんですよね…
僕が成人式だったのは、もう3年前なので
もうあれから3年経ちました。
とりあえず、あの、成人された皆様。おめでとうございます。
僕みたいな大人にならないようにしようね。
ちょっとね、僕にとって成人式はね、かなりでかいものだったので、ちょっとね
今日は僕の成人式についてちょっと話そうと思います。
面白いかはわかんないけど、
ちょっとね、いろいろね、成人式とかね、僕の中学時代についてちょっと話そうと思います。
まずですね、成人式っていうのは、結構地域で
まずですね、成人式っていうのは、結構地域で行われます。
あんまり高校のメンバーと集まるというよりかは、中学とかですね、小学校とか中学校の地域地元で集まったメンバーと
成人式で会うことが多いんですよ。
なんで、僕の成人式もその地域で集まったので、小学校中学校の友達が
たくさんいました。
ズバリ！今もなんですけども、
基本的に女の人が苦手なんですよ…
いやだいぶマシにはなったとは思うんですけども、基本的にちょっと苦手で、
なぜこんなことになったかっていうのも
ちゃんと今回はわかりやすく、説明してあげましょう！
というわけで、僕の成人式のエピソードです。
どうぞ！
というわけで、俺の成人式でございます。
まあ、成人式といえばね、スーツを着たり袴とか着たり、
女の子はねこう、なんか着物とか着て、みんなおめかしして、
うわぁ～成人！わぁ～！みたいな、ちょっと楽しい感じなんですけども、
僕はスーツで行きましたが、
まあ、ここでちょっと話がガラッと変わるんですけども、
僕は中学校の時に女友達が、
ほぼ、いません。
まずですね、大きなカギとなったのは中学2年生の秋。
僕こう見えて、中学校の時は副生徒会長やってたんで、学校の中でも
ちょっとこう、がんばって、ちょっと目立ってる系の男子だったんです。
中学生活をいい感じで送っていたんですけども、
学習発表会、文化祭みたいなのが中学校にあった秋の時期なんですけども、
もうね、その、なんかね文化祭とかでこの初めの言葉とか言うんで、
結構目立ってたんですよ。
もうねイケイケの。
結構目立ってたんで、やっぱねこうね多少なりともちょっとモテちゃってて、
モテた結果ですね、こうかわいい女の子からですね、学習発表会が終わった後に告白されまして、
「はじめくん、好き♡」みたいな
で、僕はビビったんっすよ。
ちょっとびっくりしたんですけども、まあ、ちょっとうれしくて、
まあ中学校でよくあるんですけど、あの、勢いでね付き合っちゃったとこがあって、
付き合ったんですけども、
僕が中学校の時は、みんなね携帯とかスマホとか持ってなくて、
友達と連絡するときはメールが基本でした。
パソコンのね。
僕は家にあるお父さんのパソコンで、Yahoo!でアカウントを作って、
ログインして、Yahoo!メールで毎日その子とメールをしていたわけですよ。
はじめ「今日何食べた？」
彼女「うーん？かつ丼？」
はじめ「ふーん＾＾ばいばーい」
ふふっ（笑）
いや、もっとなんか、もっとなんか話してたぞ！
いやでもね、あんまり言うとね、大好きとか好きとかね、言える感じじゃなかったのですけども
こっそりお父さんが使ってない時間を狙ってこうね、
Yahoo!メールでね、話してたわけなんですよ！
しかし！
僕は、思ったより忙しかった…。
バスケ部でゴリゴリ部活をガッツリやってたのと、
生徒会でですね、なんか副会長だったんで、地味に仕事があったので、
朝が早かったりして
もう基本的に学校で会うことはできないんですよ。
同じクラスだったんですけども、女子は女子で固まって、男子は男子で固まってたし、
僕とその子をつなぐカギは、もうYahoo!メールしかなかったんですよ。で、まあ
せっせとYahoo!メールをしていたんですけども、やっぱり
忙しくて時間がなかったのと、お父さんがパソコン使ってたりしたので
あんまりね、メールをする時間が取れずに、気づいたら…
メールをあんまりしないようになっていました。
携帯とかスマホがないとね、結構大変だったんですよ。
直接学校でね、
「今日メールできなくてごめんね」とか気を遣う言葉も言えずに、
しゃべることなく、だんだん日が進んでいきました。
何でこんなことになってしまったんだろう？
なぜかその子とは口が利けなくなり、メールも打つ気にもなれず、
お互いがこうお互いをちょっと避けるようになって、なんか
避けつつの生活が続いてしまって、
まあ付き合っているのか付き合っていないのかも、よくわからず、
女子にはね、力のね、ちょっと身分のね…この制度があると思うんですよ。
これを僕は「女子のカースト制度」と呼んでおります。
たぶん男子にもねそういう感じなのがあったと思うんですけども、
こちらに、「女子のカースト制度」の図があります。
上・中・下、とピラミッド型に分かれているんですけども、
ワイワイキャピキャピ系で、
男子カースト制度の上のグループと、上の女子のグループが仲いいみたいなね。
なんか男子もそうだと思うんですけども、なんか
中学校、高校はね、こういう謎のピラミッドのなんか、身分制度ができると思うんですよ。
僕の学校ではね。
ここでですね、僕の付き合った女の子のポジションの話をするんですけども、
女子のカースト制度のピラミッドの上層部のてっぺん！
ここです！！！
女子のカースト制度のピラミッドのてっぺんに君臨するんで、
この子こそ女子のキング！
学年の女子のトップみたいな感じの子だったんですけども、
お前ら
よーく考えてみてくれ。
女子のこのピラミッドの頂点に君臨するライオンキングとの自然消滅は何を意味するか。
そう！
すべての女子との自然消滅です。
俺は、この子と別れてから、すべての女子と口が利けなくなった。
女子は全員その子に服従しているわけじゃないですか。従っているわけなんで。
トップの女の子が気まずい俺にねぇ、
このほかの女の子が話すことはもうねタブーなんですよ。
もう、違法。違法行為だったんで、
同学年の女の子から基本的に無視され、話しかけられもせず、
まるで、空気のような存在でした。
僕の中学校時代はこの子と自然消滅してから、中学校はその後基本的に、女の子と話すことは
なかったです。
というのもあってですね、ちょっとねーなんか、苦手というかね、怖いんですよね。女子が。
いつ話してくれなくなるか分かんないからね。
ちょっと苦い、中学校時代の思い出があります。
男子は仲良くしてくれたんで、仲いい男子はいるんですけども、
カースト制度上層部の女子と仲良くできない男子が、そんななんかワイワイ出来るわけでもないので、
僕は静かに中学校生活を送っていました。
というわけで、僕の地域では僕はちょっと苦い思い出があるのでね、
基本影キャラよりだったんですけども、そういう感じで迎えました。
成人式の日でございます。
たまたまなんですけども、そのカースト制度のトップに君臨する女子と僕はですね、同じ地区に住んでおりまして、
成人式でも結構ね、会う機会があったんで、
僕は頑張って話しかけてみたんですよ。
「や、やぁ。久しぶり。」みたいな感じで話してみたんですけども、
なんか、自然と話せました。
でね、なんかね、その場の勢いでですね、「なんか昔は自然消滅したよね。ははは（笑）」みたいな話もできて、
誤解とかね、あの時はごめんねっていう話ができた、という話です。
成人式はですね、僕がちょっと悔やんでたことを1つ解決できたという思い出でございます。
まあでも、結局僕の中学校のポジションは、基本陰キャラだったんで、
成人式の2次会かな。
途中で、帰っちゃった＾＾
～♪
みんなでも成人式は楽しいもんだからね。
ぜひ楽しんでください。
じゃあな！